hello welcome to fry diary this happened
first of all oh my god now you're all in
fried I read that in a podcast with some
hilarious improviser slash writer
comedian wonderful people John Hayes for
Earwolf link down below to go listen to
the full thing guys I just did a podcast
with Hayes and Sean and Sam's back there
everybody and they were dicks but in a
great way right
hey you do yeah yeah yeah I explained to
them how YouTube worked and it got real
weird then what else happen we're
shooting some photos for the Washington
Post it's a very professional just
professional shoot there's guys doing
the picture-taking and it's just like
pro here's a quick thing that happened
welcome to behind the scenes of why dad
we write jokes we drink drinks
mamrie does that just looking angelic my
job and then slam that happens and then
slam this happens you're just fixing
your fate fix the fitnah rock ghostly to
the pin in my hair and I got some pin on
them Oh with a pair what office are you
the Secretary of oh then this happened
okay I'm here shooting with Lily need i
say more
oh my god
then this I forgot to vlog this but
Kingsley was here we just shot something
really fun that you'll see he sat right
there sure kings his butt was you guys
he's but look he's but was here there's
but here
and don't ask Oh then everyone is doing
funny things making less than make
English and make English traffic then
that happens to be ready to go to a
shoot for Funny or Die today it's 6:45
but look this happened the same day
[Music]
[Music]
well there you go there's a little sneak
peek behind my week did you hope in week
I hope you did I had a really fun one
and I hope it continues I don't know
[Music]
quick shout out to my own web series pal
self-serving a via there's a new episode
of Graces faces with Meghan Liz Meghan
and lives there are two twins that do
music and they're just so goddamn
adorable so go watch it there's an
annotation or link one of those things
also big big news okay starting 9 a.m.
Friday today basically as soon as this
video goes live until Monday January
27th 5 p.m. Pacific Standard Time in the
United States if you preorder the film
camp Takota
on Camp Takota calm you will get an
exclusive clip from the film sent to you
to download and watch on Tuesday January
28th
I believe if you've already pre-ordered
the film you're gonna get it
surprised and so if you haven't done it
already get it cuz you're gonna get a
clip and I don't even know what the clip
is but it's gonna be a good one I'm sure
cuz the whole thing makes me happy the
turn the camera off